escortée par des véhicules blindés
russes ces soldats quittent la syrie
d'azov stahl vers une destination qui
restent incertaines selon moscou des
combattants ukrainiens auraient été
évacués vers une colonie pénitentiaire
dans un territoire contrôlée par les
séparatistes soutenus par le kremlin
selon le chef de la république
autoproclamée de donetsk des combattants
ukrainien de haut rang serait toujours
retranché dans l' usine selon nos
données il y avait plus de 2000
personnes dans l'usinage au total
265 combattants sont sortis puis 617 un
peu plus de la moitié d'entre eux sont
restés à l'intérieur
en ce qui concerne les criminels de
guerre et les nationalistes
s'ils déposent les armes
sort sera entre les mains de la justice
selon moscou ces images montrent des
soldats évacués soigné dans un hôpital
de la région de donetsk
la vidéo a été filmée montée et diffusé
par le ministère russe de la défense
je me trouve dans un hôpital de la ville
de nouveau à zoss je suis bien traité
personne ne me maltraitent physiquement
ou psychologiquement ils ont regardé ma
jambe on dit qu'elle allait bien ils
nous ont donné à manger
la propagande russe présente ses hommes
comme des membres du bataillon azoff des
combattants intégrés à l'armée
ukrainienne d affirmation largement
relayée dans la propagande russe utilisé
pour justifier la guerre en ukraine est
pour l'instant peu de détails ont été
dévoilés de l'accord du 16 mai entre
kiev et moscou qui a conduit à la
reddition de combattants kiev espère que
ses hommes feront l'objet d'un échange
de prisonniers